our continuous glucose monitors the
newest disordered eating tool if you've
been on social media in recent months
you've likely seen a ton of creators
inserting big round patches into their
arms to track their blood sugars all day
I've had so many CGM Brands reach out to
me with sponsorship opportunities
basically asked me to promote these to
the masses and no matter how great they
offer I have consistently said no and
today I'm going to tell you all why
oh
[Music]
foreign
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's Kitchen
in today's video I'll be giving my
professional take on the trend toward
healthy people without diabetes using
continuous glucose monitors AKA cgf a
huge quick shout out to my colleague
Erin Davis for assisting on the research
here Aaron is a fellow Rd and diabetes
educator practicing from a weight
inclusive lens so if you are struggling
with your blood sugars definitely reach
out she is amazing and all of our
contact info and links are below also a
trigger warning that I will be
discussing disordered eating so please
keep that in mind and feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive and
finally check out the links below to my
new free downloadable HCC ebook as well
as my ltk page where you can see what
I'm wearing today okay I need to jump in
here super quick to tell you about this
product that literally changed my life
okay I'm being a little bit dramatic but
I have honestly never been more excited
and passionate about a brand that I've
partnered with let's talk about
symbiotics so I am not a huge Drinker
mainly because it hits me super hard and
even after like a single glass of wine I
am a shell of myself the next day
without fail alcohol will interrupt my
sleep and it flares up my IBS so it's
like a risk benefit analysis if I decide
to imbibe but this zbiotics probiotic
drink has literally been a game changer
ask any of our friends and family that
we go to dinner with we do not leave the
house without our zbiotics I'm currently
packing them to go to the cottage
because I know I'm going to need them
and I've literally turned everyone I
know onto this stuff because we are all
just too old to Rally after a night of
drinking but let me explain to you guys
how this works so this is the world's
first genetically engineered probiotic
that's been scientifically designed to
break down the byproduct of alcohol
acetaldehyde that's responsible for
feeling not so great the morning after
drinking so the way it works is that you
drink your bottle of sebiotics before
before you have an alcoholic drink and
the probiotic produces a unique enzyme
like the one that your liver naturally
uses to break down the byproduct
responsible for the not so fun morning
this is absolutely not an invitation to
binge drink like alcohol is still not a
healthy food and it should always be
treated as a substance to be enjoyed in
moderation as I mentioned over
consumption can lead to poor sleep
digestive distress liver damage and
probably a lot of bad decisions if I
take my zebiotic and I stick to my
modest one or two drinks Max on occasion
I wake up feeling amazing and I'm way
more likely to play with my kids in the
morning instead of putting them in front
of the TV like I said everyone in my
immediate circle is absolutely obsessed
and I don't think I will ever have a
drink without my zebiotics again so if
you want to give sleep Addis a try go to
zebiotics.com Abby sharp or scan the QR
code on the screen right now and use my
promo code Abby sharp to get 15 off of
your first order they also offer a full
money back guarantee if you're not
satisfied with your purchase but
honestly if anything you're probably
going to be disappointed that you didn't
buy more the Fourth of July weekend is
bound to have some sparklers and hot
dogs and summertime Cocktails so if you
want to avoid the rude awakening make
sure you order your zebiotics on time
okay so first up super super duper
quickly a CGM works by tracking your
blood glucose level via a sensor under
the skin that can then relay information
about your blood sugar levels in real
time often they're combined with like an
insulin a pump for folks with diabetes
to deliver the most accurate dose of
medication without having to count any
carbs or be subject to human calculation
errors we also have research on patients
with pre-diabetes and type 2 diabetes
that CGM use can potentially help
support healthy behavior modification so
for example the idea is that if an
individual with diabetes consistently
sees their blood sugar spiking after
they eat pizza for example
Pizza time it's possible that this could
encourage them to try maybe having a
salad first to try to flatten out the
curve so I do think the benefits of cgms
for the population that they've been
studied and validated AKA folks with
insulin resistance and diabetes likely
outweigh the risks we're going to
discuss but the CGM Market isn't just
stopping at the 37 million Americans
with diabetes these devices are expected
to reach over 15 billion in sales by
2030 with over 200 clinical trials
underway including studies on their use
in folks without diabetes which likely
explains why we've seen so many
non-diabetic influencers and content
creators get sponsored by CGM Brands
using it almost like an alternative
nutrition metric to like calorie
counting on MyFitnessPal
[Music]
there is now a whole genre of online
content of creators sharing them eating
like a single food and then looking at
the data from their CGM often when they
do see any kind of increase in blood
sugar make a huge deal out of it and
then they paint that food as inherently
bad take this guy eating peaches for
example he like waxes poetic about all
the important health benefits and
nutrition in a peach and then he looks
at his graph and he sees oh my God the
peach spiked his blood sugar to 9.4
millimoles per liter after which she
concludes he would be worried to add it
as a regular snack that's why peaches
have health benefits I will be worried
not to add it as a regular snack if I
want to keep my blood sugar balance
um
this the point that his blood sugar like
immediately went back down because his
pancreas is working normally to bring
blood sugars back into regular range so
suddenly one single metric has the power
to turn impressional people watching off
of a nutritious whole food like a peach
when we have ample research that a diet
rich in fruits and vegetables like
peaches peaches peaches peaches peaches
peaches help reduce the risk of diabetes
insulin resistance and obesity and
that's dangerous another common
example I've seen a lot on Tick Tock is
oatmeal we see a lot of oatslander these
days in the CGM Community if a food
could be fake news that would be oats
we've been told oats are so good for you
complex carbs digest slower good for
your blood sugar Etc but I have a CGM on
and I've tried this over and over again
and notes are a disaster and a lot of
this hate seems to be based around these
CGM readings showing that you get this
big spike post oatmeal so you got all
these people out there calling out the
idea that oatmeal is healthy fake news
with craters making these
sensationalized statements that we've
all been lied to all these years by big
corpse pushing Big oat guys this is
incredibly short-sighted and also
unnecessary fear-mongering again in
folks without diabetes that curve goes
down pretty fast and if you choose
something like rolled oats or steel cut
over quick rolled oats in the steel cut
oats are a better choice than the
instant variety oats
most people do can significantly lower
the glycemic response again looking at
each individual food's impact on blood
sugar in someone who doesn't have blood
sugar regulation problems is missing the
forest from the trees if the concern is
the risk of diabetes we actually have
specific research on oatmeal showing
that it's actually beneficial for folks
with type 2 diabetes and if weight gain
is the concern we have research showing
that Oats help to support weight loss so
yeah all this oatmeal hate is the real
fake news if you ask me but let's just
imagine that maybe you were to just eat
plain oatmeal without any protein powder
or nuts or seeds or eggs in there just
like straight up quick oats in water
which sounds like torture but
let's just work with it what is the big
deal with like a little blip in blood
sugar in healthy folks with healthy
pancreases honestly
nothing the kids are gonna be all right
fluctuations in blood glucose are
completely normal increases in blood
glucose after eating carbs is actually
how our body fuels our activity and
other healthy bodily processes in a
person without diabetes you would expect
that your pancreas will deliver the
appropriate amount of insulin to
effectively and efficiently lower that
glucose level to normal levels without
any kind of intervention at all so even
if you were to eat like a whole
container of straight up cotton candy
your blood sugar will normalize so you
don't have to like freak out about it
that doesn't mean that we want to be on
a constant blood sugar roller coaster
like if you did just eat a bin of cotton
candy you'd probably experience a bit of
an energy surge and then a bit of a
crash and ultimately that just that just
doesn't feel good and if we're
chronically exposed to a diet that's
rich in really high calorie high
glycemic index Foods eventually we can
kind of poop out our pancreas and or
increase our body fat both of which can
increase our risk of type 2 diabetes
over time so as a dietitian do I
recommend wearing a c a CGM if you don't
have diabetes well judging by the fact
that I've turned down a lot of lucrative
sponsorship deals in the past few months
it's probably clear that my answer is no
at this point there's actually very
little good data to suggest improved
Health outcomes with CGM use in folks
without diabetes one study found that in
people without diabetes blood sugar
levels were within the healthy normal
range 96 percent of the time suggesting
surprise surprise healthy people's
pancreases work in bringing those
numbers effectively down another super
super small pilot study on 19 obese
individuals found that wearing an
activity tracker and a CGM together
helped to increase their motivation to
exercise which is great but the study
was like 10 days long and I don't know
most people are motivated with like a
new expensive gadget for a few weeks
before eventually the novelty wears off
so at this time there's really no good
research to suggest any major benefits
for folks without diabetes that said I
can think of a lot of risks first of all
a blood sugar reading is just one data
point and a transient one at that and
when a single transient metric informs
what when or how much we eat we really
quickly lose trust and connection with
RNA wisdom are you coming out you know
no different than occasionally weighing
yourself or looking at the calories of
certain foods you eat an occasional
check-in on your blood sugars of course
can help to inform future choices but I
would never recommend a healthy person
weigh themselves after every single meal
so why would they need to be checking in
on any other external metric multiple
times a day that's just some food for
thought not surprisingly there is a
growing concern in the medical community
that this trend of healthy people using
cgms to track their meals will quickly
become the neck clean eating in
orthorexia diagnosis it's really
important to have
steady glucose levels throughout the day
I've learned all this recently and
become so obsessed with it so while cgms
may ease the cognitive burden on folks
with insulin dependent diabetes they're
very likely to do the complete opposite
for healthy folks I also worry about the
messaging that I see in a lot of the CGM
content online like swearing off a
perfectly healthy food like a peach
because it spikes your blood sugar may
very quickly take almost any carb
containing food completely off the table
unless it's eaten in some specific order
or with other specific Foods most people
really don't need an app to tell them
that they feel better after having like
a generally balanced meal than they do
after having a big slice of cake why do
they make this so hard for me and I do
worry that seeing that blood sugar Spike
after a celebratory piece of birthday
cake will just serve to reinforce the
common narrative that carbs are Public
Enemy Number One when in reality if that
was the case carbs wouldn't be our
body's preferred source of fuel and we
wouldn't have effective regulatory
mechanisms in the body to maintain blood
sugar homeostasis and we wouldn't have
ample evidence that there's very little
difference long term in weight loss when
we combine going low carb with low fat
this all just makes healthy eating way
too complicated
[Music]
and this is really why I created my
Hunger crushing combo I really wanted to
give people an evidence-based guideline
to like effortlessly and naturally build
out balanced meals and snacks ones that
would keep you satiated longer and help
with blood sugars without any
deprivation or Obsession I definitely
did not want people to get lost in the
details of numbers or calories or
portions or blood sugar so when you turn
a single reading into a rule that you
can never eat a naked carb again or that
you can only eat foods that basically
Flatline your blood glucose all day you
distort the data into another
potentially disordered Obsession and
listen I am all about data and knowledge
and we are so lucky today that we have a
lot of great technology to help inform
our health knowledge even if it does
cost thousands of dollars per year for
some people that will absolutely be
worth it but when we get lost in the
minutia of the health data we miss the
force from the trees we stress over the
whole meal and we lose sight of the
entire day or most importantly we forget
about the overall lifestyle including
exercise stress sleep Etc and not just
what we eat all of these things can play
a role in blood sugar control weight
management and the risk of chronic
disease it's looking good stress
specifically is a major contributor to
insulin resistance and type 2 diabetes I
think for a lot of people seeing these
numbers can be really triggering and
stressful as
so it actually may end up having the
opposite of intended effect Hold the
Line This is going to 350 for 30 to 35
minutes multitasking
anyways it is absolutely possible that
we will one day have research showing
that CGM use in non-diabetes patients
may help to detect pre-diabetes early or
it might help optimize exercise or
mental stamina but at this point like
right here right now it feels like it
mainly just serves to give people the
illusion of control over their health
so I will absolutely keep my eye on the
research and when it proves that the
benefits of us all wearing cgms outweigh
the psychological risks I will be happy
to change my tune but until then I say
focusing on energy levels hunger
alertness attention span and stamina and
thinking about building those balanced
meals allow my Hunger crushing combo is
more than enough to inform food choices
for blood sugar control and on that note
folks I've got a mess to clean up I hope
you enjoyed this video if you've got
more questions leave them below I would
love to hear your thoughts on this I
know it is a pretty sensitive topic
right now so hit up the comment section
don't forget to check out my Hunger
crushing combo ebook you can find a link
to that in my description and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye